so chuck what you got another question
yes i do and it's actually coming from
chris who is on the bone oh excellent
excellent let's go straight to it chris
thanks for calling into star talk
yeah what do you got i was wondering
about nanobots uh didn't know if they
could be considered a virus or
or not because they're not alive or
a lot of baggage there i mean could they
nanobots be controlled to where
you guys have just mentioned the zombies
maybe they can be self-aware and turn
you into a zombie or
so just to clarify there's been a lot of
loose talk with the prefix nano right
nano literally means one billionth right
so a nanosecond is a billionth of a
second a nanometer is a billionth of a
meter and so
nanobiology and nanotech technically
means
things that are the size of a billionth
of a meter very tiny tools life form
whatever it is you're doing lately i've
seen people talk about nanobots which
are just little robots that crawl around
on your desk right i mean they're small
so call them a small bot but save nano
for when you really mean it or an ipod
right and so chris's point of course is
if we can make
viruses that we control that are sort of
machine
machines but are small like viruses we
can affect you with something that we
manufactured in the lab so there is
nanotech that is targeting disease
and there is a lot of talk about
that would be nanobots for good yes
the the positive force of marvel comics
or what have you these nano
agents which are still very much in the
um i would say the front end of the
research process
um
it is imagine would target for example
killing cancer cells
so they would recognize something on the
surface of the cell that said i'm a
cancer cell and then go in and and kill
it with a poison or what have you
um but in the hands of the diabolical
evil genius well the question really is
to ask is there a way to make a nanobot
self uh reproducing mm-hmm
if it's the right way life would the way
it's a virus if a nanobot could be
self-reproducing then indeed you could
have an out of control infectious
problem
because it would have to replicate
itself yes in order for that to happen
yes like a virus would do like a virus
so then you're really walking the line
between what's man-made and what's
right at some point we're not
controlling machines we're controlling
biological molecules well and then the
other thing that is what's the
difference at that level there's no
difference what's the other thing that's
going on now is that uh we have this
dichotomy of purpose where people in
public health want to know what's going
on with viruses in the natural world so
we're ready we make our counter measures
our vaccines and what have you but on
the other hand there's a lot of folks
that say well the best way to answer
that question is to do man-made
evolution let's direct the evolution of
viruses in the lab manipulate them turn
them into monster viruses and see you
know what does it take to be a monster
virus so
um
last year
last year two different teams one in
wisconsin and one in rotterdam um indeed
made a super killer form of flu
in the lab and a whole lot of people
said why in the world would you do such
a thing yeah swallows are now sitting in
freezers right we kept them
last month not to be outdone by
americans because you know they don't
want to be outdone by americans with
anything the chinese a lab in harbin
made 127 man-made flu viruses of which
five readily spread in the air between
guinea pigs and killed them oh my god so
this is the new
the new cusp that we're on
oh we're trying to do it for good we're
trying to see in advance what nature
might do but in the process you're
putting in a freezer armageddon people
and people were afraid of physicists
the plum crazy you are not lying man
oh my god i'll take an atom bomb any day
over this yeah i gotta tell you in the
fraternity of science you guys are
animal houses
well if you don't like that check this
out no stop there no no no no no you got
something worse
okay
synthetic biology there's a competition
called igem in order to compete high
school students and college students
have to make a novel not pre-existing
microorganism in in 2012 there were 248
competing teams meaning 248 previously
non-existent microbes were made by high
school and college students that's the
end of that's the end that's the end of
the work right here's what you just told
us
you